[MUSIC]
There years ago I went on
my first date with Brian.
We had matched on a dating app and
started texting right away.
He was so enthusiastic and compassionate.
He would text me hey,
with an exclamation point.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Followed by how's it going?
>> We really hit it off.
He was just so easy to talk to.
Fast forward to our first date.
It was aweful.
>> [LAUGH]
>> We couldn't keep a conversation going,
his voice was monotone,
he failed to make eye make contact.
And he wasn't even asking questions, so
much for enthusiastic and compassionate.
Frustration set in as I counted
down the minutes until freedom.
This situation is a prime example of
what I call fictionalizing reality.
My conversations with Brian were real but
they were just texts on a screen.
No body language, no vocal cues.
I was working with an incomplete picture.
So to compensate I colored in what was
missing with bright shades of exuberance
and charm.
I had fictionalized my reality.
Technology had brought me to Brian.
But it also introduced ambiguity,
which ultimately led to my disappointment.
We are more digitally
connected than ever before,
exchanging on average 250 text
messages and emails every day.
But only so
much can be said with a digital message,
which leads to a number of challenges.
In his research on human communication,
Professor Albert Murabian hints
toward some of these challenges.
And why technology may interfere
with three critical elements of our
conversation.
Our clarity, our intention and
our vulnerability.
He explains that our non-verbal cues,
specifically our tone of voice and
body language.
Help change the attitudes and
feelings of others more so
than the actual words we say.
Let me give you an example,
I could say, I can't wait or
I can't wait.
>> [LAUGH]
>> My tone of voice and body language help
to communicate my excitement and
enthusiasm or, lack there of.
He further explains that 93% of our
impact is attributable to these
non verbal cues whereas our actual
content contributes to just 7%.
This concept also applies to
text messaging and email.
Our message communicates 7% of our message
but leaving us in the 93% darkness.
Where it's hard to detect clarity,
intention, and vulnerability.
As recipients, we're often left
feeling confused or doubtful.
As senders, anxious and misunderstood.
Both sides are left feeling disconnected,
but why?
First, technology compromises clarity.
Last week I had to cancel
plans with my friend.
I sent him a quick text explaining
the situation, expecting disappointment.
A few hours later my phone buzzed,
his response,
it's okay, I understand.
It's okay.
I understand.
[SOUND] He was definitely mad.
It's okay.
I understand.
Totally fine.
But which was it?
He hadn't used an emoji or
an exclamation point.
>> [LAUGH]
>> He must be mad.
>> This conversation had me doubting
the status of our friendship,
I was embarrassed by my flakiness.
I was afraid to reach out,
it was unclear what he was saying.
I decided I may be
overthinking everything, so
I decided to give him a call.
Sure enough he did understand, and we
re-scheduled our dinner for another night.
I had fictionalized
the 93% of his message.
He had only given me 7%.
And unfortunately for us,
as psychology research shows,
when we're given ambiguity
we tend to assume the worst.
I'm sure, as you have experienced,
even the smallest language or punctuation
choice can lead to hours, days, or
even weeks of frustration and resentment.
Secondly, technology
compromises intention.
Prior to starting my MBA
program at Standford,
I was a young business
professional on Wall Street.
Making PowerPoints and consuming
caffeine like my job depended on it.
>> [LAUGH]
>> To be clear, my job did depend on it.
>> We worked tirelessly on an extensive
pitch deck.
I was on version 16 when I sent the
document to my boss for a final review.
The next morning,
an email sat at the top of my inbox.
I took a deep breath and
clicked into the email, thx.
>> [LAUGH]
>> T-H-X period.
What?
Are you kidding me?
Did I make a mistake?
Does he know how long I spent
working on this project?
There is no way I am spending
this much time on the next one.
N-O W-A-Y, period.
>> [LAUGH]
>> This email from my boss left me
feeling unappreciated and unsupported.
This interaction wasn't uncommon with him,
but
this last message left me
feeling completely demoralized.
To the point that I considered looking for
a new role,
that is until I ran into my boss, and
he congratulated me on a job well done.
Wait, what?
To my surprise, he had been so
incredibly impressed with the pitch deck.
That he printed the deck as is,
replied with a quick THX, and moved on.
Failing to see the intention
behind his thanks,
I had fictionalized my reality yet again.
When it comes to email and texts we
are often overconfident in our ability to
convey our complete thoughts and feelings.
Assuming that the recipient shares
the same context that we do.
This can lead to problems, reducing
self-confidence and morale over time,
which can deteriorate your
important relationships.
Lastly, technology
compromises vulnerability.
My phone buzzed as I
received one text message.
Just two words,
My body fell limp in my seat.
My dad had informed me that my
only grandfather had passed away.
But his message felt abrupt,
harsh, emotionless.
What I sought in this moment was
support and strength from my dad.
But instead, I felt disconnected.
I was afraid to delve
into the 93% darkness.
I couldn't fictionalize this reality.
I failed to detect my
father's true feelings.
And I struggled to expose my
own vulnerability to him.
Again I've been provided a snippet of
content but the rest was ambiguous.
It's hard to choose the right words for
a text to email.
Making it hard to express our true
feelings in important moments like
this one.
Technology allows us to
accomplish incredible things.
But by virtue of its digital form,
it can get in the way of truth and
genuine connection.
So if you seek to build meaningful
connection, how exactly do you do that?
Strive for clarity.
Instead of it's okay, I understand.
Try it's okay, thanks for letting me know,
I'd love to catch up, let's re-schedule.
A clear tone goes a long way.
Express your intention explicitly.
Instead of replying with, thanks.
You could try, this is great,
I appreciate your hard work, thanks.
With just eight additional words my
boss could've adequately expressed his
appreciation, giving me
confidence in my work.
Convey more emotion even when difficult.
Your grandfather has passed away,
I know this is hard for all of us, but
stay strong,
call me when you can I love you.
Digital messaging is a powerful tool and
if you use it with intention,
you can wield powerful results.
You can prevent others from
fictionalizing their reality.
Instead of creating
unnecessary frustration or
distance, you can build
self confidence and morale.
Join me in tackling the dark
side of digital communication.
So we can build better relationships.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]